r surtout vous allez l'entendre pour
faciliter la vie de leurs patientes
est ce vraiment un service à leur rendre
on va se poser la question avec notre
invité dans un instant on découvre
ensemble d'abord le reportage de fleurât
sauvage interdire les certificat de
virginité et pénaliser les médecins qui
les rédigent c'est l'intention du
gouvernement à travers l'article 16 du
projet de loi sur les séparatismes
certificat délivré par un médecin sont
censés attester de la pureté d'une jeune
fille avant un mariage une pratique
jugée humiliante par le corps médical
il faut que ce certificat disparaissent
il n'a aucun sens déjà sur le plan
physique il n'a aucun sens sur le plan
éthique
on n'a jamais vu demander un certificat
de virginité pour un homme pourquoi ça
existerait pour une femme
il faut que cette idée simplement ce
concept disparaissent à la maison des
femmes en seine-saint-denis un lieu qui
accueille les personnes vulnérables est
victime de violences
rada hatem assure que les demandes sont
rares les demandes sont très
minoritaires j'en avais 2 à 4 par an
aujourd'hui depuis que le sujet est
vraiment sur le tapis j'en ai
bizarrement deux à quatre par mois avec
beaucoup beaucoup d'espèces d'appels à
l'aide j'ai 15 ans ma famille très
religieuse
souvent je propose une rencontre et
finalement il n'y a pas de suite c'est
comme si il se disait bon je vais
demander on sait jamais ce que quelqu'un
peut m'aider
puis peut-être le fait de savoir que
quelqu'un veut bien m'aider finalement
la pression retombe et je ne vois pas en
consultation mais j'ai aussi des jeunes
femmes qui viennent jusque en
consultation pour me demander
rada hatem assume de délivrer cette
attestation et aimerait que le
législateur fasse confiance au médecin
qui comme elle sont sur le terrain en
pénalisant les médecins en fait on
supprime une ressource aux femmes un
lieu où elles peuvent justement parlé de
ses traditions néfastes ces contraintes
qui leur pourrissent la vie pour cette
femme qui préfère garder l'anonymat des
certificat de virginité permettent de
protéger les personnes qui les demandent
kkr
religion rien faire tel en région ou la
rigidité et criquets importante
quand je pense qu'avec cette attestation
de les imiter cette fin pourra se
défendre
marc mathilde de l'espine est sage femme
s'il s'agit d'une pratique d'un autre
temps elles assurent agir dans l'intérêt
des femmes
on réfléchit toujours dans nos actes
médicaux a d'abord ne pas nuire et peser
la balance bénéfices risques est parfois
on se résout à ce certificat
quand on pense que c'est la moins
mauvaise solution
même si on ne cautionne pas dans cet
atelier théâtre proposée à la maison des
femmes
les participantes sont invitées à
partager les difficultés qu'elles
rencontrent
si la mesure est votée telle quelle les
médecins qui délivre ses certificats
encourront une peine allant jusqu'à un
an de prison et 15000 euros damende le
sénat débutera l'examen du projet de loi
sur les séparatismes le 30 mars en
commission et allons plus loin avec
notre invité dans l'entretien ce soir
israël nisand bienvenue vous êtes
professeur de gynécologie obstétrique à
l'université de strasbourg
spécialiste en procréation médicalement
assistée vous présidez le forum européen
de bioéthique
il y a donc des endroits où on accepte
de faire des certificat de virginité
qu'est ce que vous en pensez est ce que
vous trouvez cela aberrant
les femmes musulmanes s'y opposent les
imams s'y oppose donc ce n'est pas une
question de religion qui demande ça le
pouvoir des hommes sur le corps des
femmes
il faut arrêter ça faut arrêter de
soumettre les femmes au pouvoir masculin
c'est un vieux reliquat du patriarcat et
dire qu'on protège les femmes en faisant
de temps en temps ce genre de sertic à
et bien tout simplement les maintient
dans la dépendance par rapport aux
hommes de leur famille s'il n'y a plus
de certificat possible en france il n'y
en a plus y en a plus elles iront
peut-être à l'étranger pour les fermer
en france il n'y en a plus j'espère bien
que les médecins qui continue
imaginez qu'il protège les femmes ainsi
respecteront la loi et ne feront plus ce
genre de certificats il faut se sortir
de la dépendance maladive des femmes à
l'égard des hommes les hommes pensent
être propriétaire du corps des femmes
et ça il faut mettre fin à ça dans notre
pays je voudrais un point de vue médical
est-ce que la virginité à une réalité
médicale physique physiologique
si je veux savoir si une femme est
vierge comment je fais je lui demande si
je veux savoir si un homme est vierge
comment je fais je lui demande être
vierge ce n'est pas avoir un hymen
attaque parce que l'hymen à des formes
extrêmement variables dont souvent on
n'arrive pas à savoir si il était là
stick ou s'il a été rompue donc l'examen
de l'hymen est une affaire compliquée
avec beaucoup de faux positifs et
beaucoup de faux négatifs
il y a la moitié des femmes qui ne
saigne pas lors du premier rapport
ce qui veut dire que l'hymen est très
élastique et ne se déchirera que lors du
premier accouchement et donc dire si une
femme est vierge
ce n'est physiquement pas possible ou
alors avec une marge d'erreur
considérable ça c'est l'avis médical
donc les médecins le savent bien qui
n'évalue plus alors proposé de faire du
certificat sans avoir examiné les femmes
ce que certains médecins font par penser
humanitaire s'est proposé de faire des
faux certificats
je propose qu'il n'y ait plus de
certificat et que cette démarche soit
interdite et pénalement réprimés si on
en revient au médical ça veut dire que
lorsqu'on fait un certificat de
virginité finalement on entretient
l'autre dans une forme de mythe de
mensonges qui n'a aucune réalité ces
entretiens l'ignorance des autres c'est
la pérennité d'un mensonge est
d'ailleurs ma question à ceux qui
continuent de faire des certificats
c'est puissent qu'ils examinent les
femmes
que font-ils et que rédige t-il
lorsqu'il voit qu'il n'ya plus de
virginité un faux certificat encore une
fois non il faut arrêter cette mascarade
des siècles qu'on parle aux jeunes
femmes
de la question de perdre sa virginité ça
va au-delà du médical là on parle
carrément d'éthique de philosophie de
religion la femme perd quelque chose
lorsqu'elle elle a des rapports sexuels
avec avec un homme c'est aussi dans les
termes dans le vocabulaire dans les
champs lexicaux qu'on emploie de pluie
depuis des siècles pour ne pas dire plus
le lait depuis la nuit des temps le
corps des femmes est d'ailleurs le corps
des enfants est la propriété des hommes
normal qu'ils se battent pour maintenir
ce privilège
et ce privilège s'exprime sur le fait
que la parole des femmes sur le leurs
antécédents n'a aucune valeur as tu dit
t'as jamais eu de rapport mais je te
crois pas je t'emmène chez le médecin on
va vérifier ça il faut arrêter que ça
ait lieu depuis des sectes c'est une
affaire entendue mais le patriarcat est
une très ancienne affaire qu'il faille y
mettre fin
dans notre pays qui est préoccupé par
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
ça c'est aussi très clair le lot la loi
contre le séparatisme va interdire et
même punir les médecins qui
pratiqueraient certificat de virginité
est ce qu a pas un risque que ces jeunes
femmes sont obligées d'aller voir un ami
pseudo un peu soignants qui rêvent
vérifier à sa place est ce que ce n'est
pas aussi éloignée ces femmes d'un d'un
médecin en bonne et due forme j'allais
dire officiels qui pourraient quand même
l'aider et les mettre dans une forme de
clandestinité dangereuse il y a très peu
de médecins qui aujourd'hui accepte de
faire un examen de virginité et les
quelques médecins qui reste le fond dans
le fond pour de très bons motifs
j'allais dire humanitaire mais il ya des
moments où la liberté des femmes et leur
autonomie par rapport aux hommes le
principe va prévaloir
et donc si plus aucun médecin est
autorisé à faire cela il s'adosse seront
à la loi pour dire ce qu'ils font encore
et bien madame c'est interdit que feront
les femmes qui en ont absolument besoin
iront elles à l'étranger pour rédiger ce
genre de sertic à je ne le pense pas on
va perdre l'habitude en occident de
procéder à ce genre de
différence entre les hommes et les
femmes demande-t-on des certificat de
virginité pour les hommes
et pourtant ils perdent tout autant leur
vigie virginité lors du premier rapport
on vous avait fait déjà ce genre de
demande à vous a déjà demandé des
certificats de virginie car oui il m'est
arrivé de voir un père a mené une une
fille de 11 ans qui avait eu une
mauvaise note à l'école et si elle une
mauvaise note à l'école c'est parce
qu'elle couche et si elle couche elle
n'a plus aucune valeur pour moi
alors vous allez me faire ça et vite
qu'est-ce que vous avez répondu j'ai
répondu qu'il n'en était pas question
il s'est mis à être violents avec tout
mon entourage avec les personnels j'ai
dû appeler la police
donc on est dans des formes de prêts
délinquance de violence à l'égard des
femmes est la pire des violences pour le
corps médical serait d'obtempérer il a
pu vous arriver aussi d'expliquer les
choses et que ça passe par le dialogue
et que ça marchera aussi avec le parent
en question oui et il m'est arrivé que
des mères amènent leur fille et que l
accepte de comprendre qu'il s'agit d'une
manière terrible de ne pas faire
confiance à la parole d'une femme
et pourquoi cette parole n'aurait aucune
valeur si la parole de la femme n'a
aucune valeur c'est qu'elle est réduite
à l'état d'animal à l'état de corps à
l'état d'objet et donc certaines mères
l'ont compris et vous savez c'est les
maires qui entretiennent malheureusement
la soumission des femmes à la règle
masculine on va élargir un petit peu si
vous le voulez bien professeur nisand
parce que vous êtes je crois beaucoup
intervenu auprès des jeunes pour leur
parler sexualité
qu'est-ce que vous avez constaté ce que
vous avez le sentiment que les jeunes
aujourd'hui sont mieux informés sur la
sexualité trop informés mal informés
comment vous observez leur relation au
sexe et comment ils la prennent alors
d'abord je trouve que le romantisme est
toujours très présent c'est une vraie
oui il ya une très bonne nouvelle c'est
que ils sont très romantique très
anxieux à l'égard de la sexualité comme
tout le monde peut l'être et que leur
début en matière de sexualité sont
perturbées par les images
auxquels ils ont accès sans aucune
limitation ni de temps ni de fascination
ils sont fascinés excité par ces images
qui d'une certaine manière les chocs
certains jeunes de 10 11 ans ont une
addiction à ces images et ne peuvent pas
quitter l'écran des yeux pendant des
heures vous pouvez consommer de la
pornographie très choquant pendant des
heures sans que l'on vous fasse payer
quoi que ce soit je trouve que nous des
failles on est les parents nous disent
aidez nous à protéger nos enfants on a
mis des contrôles sur les ordinateurs à
la maison mais regarde ça sur les
smartphones dans la cour de récréation
et je suis frappé par les questions
anonyme rédigée en classe de 4e et 3e
par des jeunes qui disent comment se
fait-il que les femmes aiment le sexe
avec les animaux comment se fait-il que
on puisse avoir une sexualité avec des
enfants comment se fait-il qu'on puisse
prôner la sexualité en famille et donc
ce sont des questions que je ne voyais
pas ya vingt ans que je ne voyais pas ya
quinze ans je situe le début de ces
questions à l'arrivée deux des sites
pornographiques
donc c'est s'était pas les fines qui se
vendait je mens je n'ai rien contre la
pornographie consommés par des adultes
qui peuvent créer la distance nécessaire
et bien voir qu'il s'agit de documents
qui sont faits pour pour les excités
mais un enfant de 10 ans quand vous lui
dites ce n'est pas vrai les femmes
n'aiment pas la sexualité avec des
animaux xixe mais c'est pas vrai
monsieur ce que vous racontez
j'ai bien entendu les bruits qu'elle
faisait quand elle le faisait et donc
c'est l'image c'est du son c'est de la
vérité il n'ya pas l'appareil critique
pour pour s'en détacher
il ya tout un travail de déconstruction
affaire avec vous avec les parents avec
qui d'autre et ce travail est très
difficile à faire
d'abord parce que les parents on va les
protéger et ne pas leur dire ce qu'on a
vu et donc les parents sont hors jeu
et quand il ya un tiers comme ça peut se
passer dans une école parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'associations beaucoup de gens
qui sont préoccupés que ces jeunes
n'aille pas chercher de l'information
sur internet parce que c'est en fait une
désinformation mais qu'ils aillent
chercher l'information chez des adultes
d'ailleurs il ya eu une plainte de
documents qu'ils sont en train de se
faire c'est que ce tuto et c'est pour
dire
et bien si on a porté cette information
de manière propre à nos jeunes et pas
avec des documents qui sont fait pour
choquer qui sont faits pour être vendus
qui sont faits pour être achetés et qui
se sont véritablement je ne comprends
pas qu'en donnant des documents à des
jeunes dans la rue on se fasse arrêter
et quant à eux en prison et qu'on puisse
librement les abreuver de ces documents
sur internet
je suis favorable à ce qu'il y ait un
contrôle de l'âge et non pas vous avez
18 ans oui non page suivante
non non un vrai contrôle de l'âge pour
que nos jeunes ne soient plus exposées à
ce prêt-à-porter sexuelle qui leur saute
aux yeux
avant il fallait le chercher plus
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous êtes ça
vient à eux et je pense qu'il faut
protéger nos enfants contre ce à partir
de quel âge et on peut commencer à leur
en parler et je pense qu'il faut en
parler à ses taux vers 9-10 ans pour
leur dire que ça leur fait du mal de
regarder ça ils sont tous au courant
parce que quand on le leur proposant la
cour de récréation s'ils veulent pas le
regarder
ils sont sont liés donc il faut les
protéger
extrêmement tôt en leur disant que ça
leur fait du mal que ce n'est pas la
réalité est que ça correspond à des
images qui n'ont rien à voir avec la
relation entre un homme et une femme qui
est toujours consentante
si vous observez ce qui se passe dans la
pornographie c'est un apprentissage au
non consentement
je suis choqué de voir qu'on a fait des
lois contre les gens qui harcèlent dans
la rue sans s'adresser et sans faire ce
qu'il faut pour empêcher que nos jeunes
s'imaginent qu'un mâle correct c'est un
mal qui agressent les femmes et qui s'il
est satisfait correctement sera remercié
en retour
je voudrais qu'on aborde un autre sujet
avec vous c'est celui des violences
obstétrical et gynécologique alors il
commence tout juste à émerger au travers
de témoignages assez édifiant de jeunes
femmes à l'image de marine gabriel qui
est la créatrice d'un compte instagram
qui s'appelle balances ton utérus
elle a aussi publié un livre la vérité
au bout des lèvres combattre les
violences obstétrical et gynécologique
la jeune femme dénonce les violences
dont sont victimes les femmes soit la
maternité soit dans les cabinet de
gynécologie
on va l'écouter quelques secondes et
vous me dites que vous en pensez après
on fait le premier la première
échographie endovaginales donc c'est une
sonde qu'on insère dans le vagin pour ba
pouvoir pour voir l'utérus pour voir où
est placée l'embryon et c'est donc déjà
bien sûr il va il me demande pas mon
avis moi j'avais jamais vu ça de ma vie
il m'en font ça comme ça ça me fait un
mal de chien je dis qu'il me fait mal
aimés ils appellent choix et donc il me
fait l'essai télégraphie et me dit
mademoiselle c'est vraiment étrange vous
n'êtes pas enceinte silva l'embryon oui
bah vous fait sûrement une grossesse
extra utérine
donc du coup il va falloir faire une
image et donc une interruption médicale
de grossesse
voilà faut revenir fois avorté il mois
en fait au fond de moi déjà c'est un
gros choc parce que ma grossesse était
très désirée voilà il n'y avait qu'elle
a donnée à melty et il ya plein d'autres
détails assez terrible qu'elle donne et
elle n'est pas la seule
est ce que vous aviez conscience qu'il y
avait un problème pas ce point là et
soyons clairs je ne je ne suis pas dans
le déni par rapport à ça il y à 95% des
gynécologues obstétriciens et des sages
femmes qui font leur travail et qu une
conscience professionnelle du
gentillesse une empathie extraordinaire
il ya malheureusement comme dans toutes
les professions
soit des gens qui sont maladroits soit
des gens qui n'ont pas l'empathie que
tout le monde souhaiterait la prise de
conscience de cela notamment au niveau
du collège national des gynécologues
obstétriciens que je présidais jusqu'au
mois de janvier nous amène à constituer
une commission bientraitance qui
s'appelle la commission probité qui est
dirigée par le professeur amina yamgnane
et qui va proposer des formations que
nous allons commencer incessamment sous
peu
disponible pour les maternités pour
expliquer
où peuvent se nicher les maltraitances
et elles peuvent se nicher à plein
d'endroits chaque dossier différent
lorsque j'entends ce témoignage je suis
hors de moi parce que ça salit la
profession et faire un examen
complémentaire à madame n'y a pas le
choix mais il ya toujours le choix il y
a toujours le choix d'abord d'être
informés correctement et de pouvoir le
refuser et donc pour moi je ne le
faisais pas jusqu'à il ya très peu de
temps quand une femme s'installer dans
mon cabinet pour être examiné je compte
pensait qu'elle était consentante
désormais je lui demande madame est ce
que je peux est ce que vous êtes prête
attendez encore un petit peu s'il vous
plaît et ça change tout parce que le jet
ski était quasiment automatique devient
consentis c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas
d'intrusion dans le corps d'une femme
sans qu'elle ait dit oui parce que sinon
vous le savez il ya près d'une femme sur
cinq qui a vécu des violences sexuelles
pendant son enfance
souvent elle a oublié et recouvert sa de
strap d'oubli pour pouvoir exister
et quand un nouvel événement de ce type
se reproduit ça fait un court circuit et
tout va être mal vécu un accouchement
d'une femme qui a vécu des violences
sexuelles et dont les médecins ne le
savent pas parce qu'ils n'ont pas posé
de questions peut être d'une violence
inouï pour la femme
alors que tout le monde s'est bien
comportée donc dans le terme violence
obstétricales que je conteste parce que
il n'y a pas de vieux volonté délibérée
dans les violences conjugales il ya une
volonté délibérée dans les violences ce
qu'on appelle les violences
obstétricales
c'est en fait de la maltraitance et
cette maltraitance et souvent non
volontaire de la part des équipes parce
que si elle est volontaire c'est un
délit et voir qu une maltraitance et
volontaire moi je conseille aux femmes
de porter plainte
il ya malheureusement quoi là c'est un
comportement automatisé robotisés une
forme d'un d'insensibilité au corps de
la femme parce qu'on a vu que ça pendant
toute sa formation et toute sa carrière
le sexe d'une femme pour elle-même et
sexualisé messieurs pour un
professionnel
c'est un organe et il est des sexualisé
cette rencontre là cette préparation à
cette rencontre là n'avait pas lieu chez
les médecins de ma génération on n'a pas
été formés à prendre préoccupations des
antécédents d'une femme du fait qu'elle
doit donner son accord à toutes les
étapes qu'elle peut le retirer à chaque
moment on n'a pas été formés maintenance
et formation commence la jeune
génération est extraordinaire de ce
point de vue ils ont intacte une
empathie formidable et je pense qu'on va
continuer de pouvoir former les équipes
de médecins deux sages-femmes à prévenir
autant que faire se peut ce qu'on
appelle le stress post traumatique de
l'accouchement qui touche près de 2 3 %
de femmes ce sont des femmes qui peuvent
plus avoir de rapports sexuels
un accouchement qui font un tour de
trois kilomètres autour de la maternité
pour ne surtout pas la voir parce
qu'elles ont été blessés par ce qui leur
est arrivé dans la maternité elles ont
souvent même pas dit aux professionnels
ce qui leur était arrivé donc avec un
label qu'on a mis en place pour les
maternités
nous sommes en train par une application
de recueillir les informations que les
femmes peuvent donner directement à
l'application et qui nous permettront de
faire un retour vers la maternité en dix
ans là il ya quelqu'un qui se comporte
pas très bien chez vous il ya quelqu'un
qui a des phrases malheureuses
il ya quelqu'un qui fait des gestes
brutaux sans consentement est parfois
les chefs de service ou les cadres
sages-femmes ne le savent même pas mais
là ils vont pouvoir le savoir mais ce
que vous décrivez ne concerne pas
seulement les gynécologues c'est à dire
qu on entend souvent cette question de
du manque d'empathie des grands pontes
ou des des médecins en général parce
qu'ils ont eu cette relation au corps
qui n'est pas la même évidemment que
celle du patient pendant les études de
médecine il n'y a pas de cours de
communication de psychologie une manière
de d'aborder le patient avec un peu de
finesse vous
on l'apprend ça on la prend maintenant
on la prend maintenant
j'allais dire depuis une dizaine
d'années dans les études de médecine
donc qui vont former tous les
spécialistes
mais tout particulièrement dans notre
discipline parce que nous sommes les
médecins de l'intimité et que cette
intimité là c'est pas la même chose de
faire un examen gynécologique que de
palper un foie ou de faire un examens
cardiologiques et donc on apprend
maintenant aux jeunes que ce soit dans
les études de médecine ou dans
l'internât à prendre des précautions
formidable et je dois dire que je n'ai
pas vu de jeunes internes rechigner à
mettre en oeuvre une une empathie
quand on les forme et qu'on leur dit
c'est important pour le patron je peux
vous dire qu'ils le font un autre sujet
encore parce que depuis quelques mois ya
une proposition de loi qui poursuit son
chemin parlementaire avait autorisé
l'accès à l'avortement jusqu'à la 14e
semaine de grossesse
le texte n'a pas encore pu passer en
seconde lecture à l'assemblée mais au
sénat le texte a de toute façon était
rejeté au grand dam d'ailleurs de la
sénatrice laurence rossignol que vous
connaissez qui elle défend c'est très
fort en écoute et on en parle pour au
moins deux mille femmes
cette situation est source d'inégalités
puisqu'elles prennent leur ivg à leur
charge sur leurs frais la sécurité
sociale ne les rembourse pas et que je
ne peux m'empêcher de noter l'hypocrisie
qui est la nôtre de compter sur nos
voisins sur les pays autour de nous pour
faire ce que nous ne voulons pas faire
d'autres se résigne à demander une
interruption médicale de grossesse pour
motif de détresse psychosocial
procédures contraignantes mais surtout
procédure qui prive la femme de son
autonomie puisqu'il faut l'accord
préalable d'un collège des médecins
israël nisand est ce qu'il ya une
hypocrisie française à ne pas vouloir
prolonger ce délai
l'avortement alors que d'autres en
europe le fond savez je suis dans un
endroit où il ya 6500 d'essence et plus
de 1000 avortements par an voilà depuis
vingt ans qu'on n'a plus envoyé personne
à l'étranger
quel que soit l'âge gestationnel comment
fait-on quand une femme téléphone le
matin en dix ans j'aurais besoin d'une
ivg je me suis enfin décidé l ai vu
l'après-midi le même show et liv et j'ai
a lieu dans la semaine
et quand la femme est au delà du délai
de peut bien c'est pas facile de mesurer
un délai c'est pas un jour précis à plus
ou moins cinq jours quand elle est à 12
+5 ou 14 +5 puisque en parlant semaines
d'aménorrhée on considère qu'on est dans
l'incertitude et ont fait bénéficier de
cette incertitude aux femmes se fait
presque 15 semaines
et quand on dépasse encore plus le délai
c'est que ce soit on est dans un déni de
grossesse
ça nécessite une prise en charge parce
que le prochain déni de grossesse peut
se terminer par un fait divers
sonné chez une toute jeune qui connaît
pas son corps et qui était pas capable
de savoir qu'elle était enceinte
et là aussi ça nécessite une prise en
charge s'agit pas pour nous d'envoyer en
hollande et j'ai toujours interdite dans
mon service qu'on envoie à l'étranger
des femmes pour une ivg est placée
jusqu'à 22 semaines c'est pour ça mais
ce que je souhaite et je vais vous dire
je n'ai jamais rencontré deux femmes qui
souhaitent une ivg tardives
j'ai rencontré beaucoup de femmes qui
souhaitent qu'on s'en occupe tout de
suite et pas qu'on leur donne rendez
vous dans trois quatre semaines parce
qu'on n'a pas les moyens
donnons les moyens aux maternités qui
roule sur les jantes 50% des maternités
interrogé son sujet on dit on n'a pas
les moyens d'agir
donnons leur les moyens et dont leur en
termes de personnel et vérifions qui
vont utiliser correctement ses moyens
pour donner un rendez-vous aux femmes
tout de suite
liv et j'ai c'est une urgence et on ne
fait pas attendre les femmes
et quand on ne les fait pas attendre ce
n'est pas deux mille femmes qui ont
besoin d'aller à l'étranger
ces quelques dizaines qui sont en déni
et qu'on doit
garder chez nous et traités par liège et
psychosociale en d'autres termes je suis
en train de dire que si on allonge le
délai on pourra dire tranquillement aux
femmes madame rassurez vous on n'a pas
le temps de vous prendre maintenant
parce qu'il y en a pas assez de
personnel mais comme le délai rallongé
on vous fera une ivg plus tardive
est-ce que c'est rendre service aux
femmes de faire ça je préfère infiniment
qu'on dise on n'en voit plus personne à
l'étranger
on gère tout dans notre pays mais on
donne des moyens pour faire les ivg et
je crains que si on allonge le délai on
se dispense de donner les moyens
quand on n'y connaît pas grand chose
douze ou quatorze semaines nous non
médecins ne savons pas exactement ce que
ça change réellement est-ce que
médicalement ça change quelque chose de
faire un avortement à 14 semaines c'est
plus difficile
plus l'âge de la grossesse est avancé
plus le geste c'est difficile et plus il
est susceptible d'entraîner des
complications
certes pas nombreuses mais vous savez
j'ai été à l'origine de l'allongement du
délai en 2001 de 12 à 14 semaines
d'aménorrhée 30 % des médecins ont
arrêté en dix ans et en me faisant
savoir puisque c'est comme ça je n'en
ferai pas je leur ai dit mais pourquoi
parce que c'est plus difficile et on a
interrogé les médecins du collège
national pour savoir si le délai est
allongé qu'est ce qu'ils feront la
moitié disent la moitié de ce qui reste
10 j'en ferai plus
donc le problème est le suivant c'est
que c'est gentil de décider au sénat de
ce que les médecins doivent faire le
geste est plus difficile et plus
dangereux et il va entraîner une
certaine déréliction si c'est voter donc
on a déjà un système d'orthogénie qu est
fragile je peux vous dire que si une
telle loi passe et ça ne rendrait pas
service aux femmes parce qu'on aurait
encore moins de médecins pour les faire
et ce sera la conclusion de cet
entretien merci infiniment israël nisand
d'avoir été à notre invité ce soir dans
l'entretien daele pl